here at the UN climate conference in
Bonn Germany representatives from almost
every country in the world are gathering
to discuss how to combat global warming
it's the 23rd time that we've done this
so you think it's a settled manner that
climate change is real it's man-made and
it's a danger to all of them think again
there's still some people who refused to
believe that climate change is real u.s.
President Donald Trump is the best
example
he's called climate change for hopes
time and time again so how can we
convince people like president Chopp
that the planet is in danger well it's
time to bust some climate change earnest
myth number one global warming can be
real because the winters are getting
colder
global warming means the average
temperature of the earth is increasing
so it's not important you know what is
the highest point of what is the lowest
point of any particular year in fact of
any particular month what is important
is the trend 16 of the hottest years
ever recorded in history has been over
the past 17 years
in fact 2017 was the hottest year on
record before it was 2016
before that it was 2015 you get the idea
right myth number two
climate change is normal the climate has
changed before and heat waves have
happened before right it is normal for
climate to be changing but the
human-driven forcing is more than ten
times faster and much greater than any
of the natural processes now the
temperature has risen such that even the
coolest years are warmer than what they
were 50 years ago we're now out of the
range of natural
over the past 800,000 years we have
never seen the extreme temperature and
the extreme co2 concentration in that we
have seen right now so yes there is a
certain degree of variability but never
under any circumstances the excess that
we have right now myth number three
there's no consensus that climate change
is really happening yeah there is no
consensus unless you ask the
nobel-winning scientists that study
climatology and the scientists from
around the world have studied this for
decades I would like to know if there's
consensus of gravity is actually working
upon us because it's the same thing the
scientific academies of every nation in
the world have found in their scientific
deliberations that climate change is
real the global warming is a threat and
it presents a existential risk to the
people of the world see you two limits
will harm the economy and the switch to
renewable energy will cost a lot of jobs
that is one of the silly stories and
that's what we call a competition the
truth of the matter is California with
its strong renewable energy it's very
far reaching greenhouse gas reduction
set of policies our economy grows faster
than the national average that is very
good proof that green energy wind solar
new electricity grid battery storage
electric cars hydrogen cars all of this
creates new jobs the jobs of the future
myth number 5 climate change isn't
harmful well just look at the world
around us right now look at all the
catastrophes that our natural disasters
Johannesburg where we've had floods I
mean in 20 minutes flat how you had
rains that were pouring down that washed
cars of me you had sea-level rising to a
point where it was going into the city
that has never been the case before so
if anybody is saying that you know
there's no harm in the change of climate
I think they need to have their head
examined
number six it's too late anyway we're
doomed and there's nothing we can do
no it's not too late you can see we
still have coastal cities right we would
like to keep them we're all doomed
eventually because we end up in the
grave but we don't have to have the
civilization end up in the grave if we
stop our greenhouse gas emissions and we
can so pessimism is really stupid we
ought to take a intelligent cautiously
optimistic approach still not convinced
the climate change is real and that's we
need to get our act together well then
here's one last message from climate
leaders usually when the entire world
gets behind something and you can think
of all the things the entire world's
behind which is climate change and
you're still saying it doesn't exist
maybe it's time to look in the mirror we
are faced with the greatest challenge
that humanity has ever faced but we have
a choice we can either continue business
as usual or we can actually make a
difference make different policy
decisions shift capital encourage even
more and more exponentially progressive
technology and we can actually create a
safer more stable better and more just
world it is happening you either believe
it or you don't you either become part
of the solution or you remain a program
but it is happening and we need all
hands on deck